logitech is unveiling a new gaming
handheld a september nintendo direct is
happening and confusion over the new
assassin's creed all this and more on
today's gamespot news
logitech is unveiling its own gaming
device on september 21st in the wake of
valve's successful handheld steam deck
the pc peripheral manufacturer is
attempting its own portable gaming
console although it will be
significantly different compared to what
is available on the market already the
product which logitech is partnering
with gaming giant tencent on will have a
focus on streaming games the company
revealed that it is working with
microsoft and nvidia to make sure that
their services xbox cloud gaming and
geforce now respectively work smoothly
on the device it seems however that the
device won't solely be for streaming
games images of the device that leaked
in august showed a google play icon
front and center in the console's home
screen which if indicative of the final
os that will ship with the device
suggests that the hardware's processor
will be beefy enough to run native
android games as well a tease for the
september 21 event reveals that the
device will have a yellow button adorned
with the logitech logo identical to the
one in the leaks confirming the validity
of those images from one handheld to
another and nintendo direct is happening
tomorrow september 13th the company not
breaking its streak of having a
september direct every year since 2016.
it will include roughly 40 minutes of
new information focusing on games coming
to nintendo switch this winter multiple
games are rumored to be part of the
presentation including two ports of the
legend of zelda windwaker hd and
twilight princess hd as well as a
remaster of the original metroid prime
pokemon scarlets and violet which are
scheduled to release on november 18th
should feature during the event as well
other than metroid prime 4 and the
breath of the wild sequel nintendo's
first party slate of officially
announced games after scarlet and violet
is completely unknown here's hoping for
mario kart9 just kidding they're going
to sell mario kart 8 forever why do you
think its logo is infinity
another showcase of games that happened
over the weekend was ubisoft forward
which included a presentation on
assassin's creed celebrating its 15th
anniversary a smaller ac-1 inspired
title called mirage will release early
next year set in baghdad and featuring a
young beseem a side character in 2020's
assassin's creed valhalla two additional
games for console and pc similar in
scope to the recent larger entries were
also announced project red will allow
players to finally climb around feudal
japan as a shinobi and the spooky
project hexe which is rumored to be set
during the holy roman empire and focus
on the witch trials of that period red
and hexey will kick off ubisoft's hub
for assassin's creed infinity which
ubisoft has confirmed will feature
multiplayer elements in the future
following the showcase fans discovered
that the xbox.com product page for
assassin's creed mirage listed an
adults-only rating for the game the
reason as to why this happened seemed to
be because the game would include real
gambling as listed as well on that
product page this didn't make much sense
as all three of the console stores don't
allow ao games seem hides them by
default and twitch doesn't allow them to
be streamed on its platform despite this
as well as ubisoft's own showcase
including an adults-only rating at the
top of the show a spokesperson for the
company told digital trends the
following quote following the
announcement of assassin's creed mirage
during ubisoft forward some store pages
mistakenly displayed the game for
pre-orders with an adult's only esrb
rating while assassin's creed mirage is
still pending rating ubisoft wants to
reassure players that no real gambling
or loot boxes are present in the game
for those looking forward to call of
duty's big next event on thursday a
quick psa playstation players that have
access to the beta this weekend can
pre-load starting 10 a.m pacific on
wednesday september 14th ahead of it
kicking off on friday september 16th
and that is it for today's gamespot news
has that logitech handheld peaked your
curiosity what are you hoping for from
tomorrow's nintendo direct let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
tomorrow for more gamespot news
[Music]
you